[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARA ROBINSON: Welcome
to machine learning APIs
by example.
I'm going to teach you how
you can use pre-trained APIs
to access pre-trained models
with a single REST API request.
My name is Sara Robinson.
You can find me on
Twitter at srobtweets,
and I'm a developer advocate on
the Google Cloud Platform team.
I focus on big data
and machine learning.
I'm based in New York.
This is my first time in Poland.
I'm super excited to be here.
So before I get started--
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
I want to talk about
what machine learning is.
So at a high level,
machine learning
is teaching computers
to recognize patterns
in the same way
that our brains do.
So over time, as
machine learning
models are given more
examples and experience
they can improve.
And with more data they're able
to generate better predictions.
So it's really easy for
a child to differentiate
between a picture
of a cat or a dog.
But it's much, much more
difficult to teach a computer
to do the same thing.
So let's pretend for a
minute that we don't have
any machine learning models.
We don't have any
deep neural networks.
And let's try some human
powered image detection.
So if we take these two images
of an apple and an orange,
and we were to
write an algorithm
to differentiate
between these two,
what are some things
we might look for?
You can shout it out.
Color, I heard color,
that's a good one.
So if we looked for
color, we could say,
are the majority of the
pixels in the image red?
If so, it's an apple.
Otherwise it's an orange.
And that would work pretty
well in this example.
But what if we had
grayscale images?
Then we'd have to
start over again.
What are some things
you might look for now?
Stem, texture.
Those are all good ones.
We could look at those
different qualities.
And that would take into
account the grayscale images.
But then what if we got crazy
and added a third fruit?
What if we added a
mango to the equation?
Then we have to
start all over again.
So you get the idea.
But these images are
all pretty similar.
They're all images of fruit.
They're relatively circular.
So the image
classification should
be a lot easier if we have two
images that look nothing alike,
right?
So what if we have a
picture of a dog and a mop?
They have pretty much
nothing in common.
The mop is not
living or breathing,
it has no eyes, nose, or ears.
It's actually kind of
difficult. So here we
have pictures of sheep dogs
and mops, four of each.
It's actually kind of hard
even for the human eye
to be able to distinguish
between the two.
So the point I'm
trying to make here
is, what if we have
photos of everything?
We don't know exactly
what photos our users
and our application
might upload.
Might not just be photos
of fruit or animals.
We're probably going to have
photos of all sorts of things.
And in addition to photos
we might have other types
of unstructured data.
So you might have
video, audio, or text.
And on Google Cloud
Platform we have
two ways to help you make sense
of this unstructured data.
So on the left hand
side, if you want
to use custom data to build and
train your own machine learning
models from scratch
we have TensorFlow,
which is an open source
library to help you do that.
And if you want to run your
TensorFlow models on managed
Google infrastructure you can
use Cloud Machine Learning
Engine.
What I want to focus on
today is the right hand side.
And this is what I like to
call friendly machine learning.
So these are APIs that give you
access to pre-trained models
with a single REST API request.
So I'm going to cover
all of these APIs
in this presentation,
and I'll dive right
in with the Vision API.
The Vision API lets you
do complex image detection
with a simple REST API request.
And before I get
started, I want to talk
about some companies
that are using
the Vision API in production.
So the first one, the example
on the left is Disney.
And they use the Vision API
for a game that promoted
their movie "Pete's Dragon."
And what the game did was it
was a scavenger hunt type game
that sent users on
a quest where they
had to take a picture
of a certain item, maybe
a couch or a computer.
And if they took a
picture of that item,
the app would superimpose an
image of Elliott the dragon
on that photo.
So they needed a way to
verify, did the user's image
match the clue
that it was given?
And the Vision API was
a great fit for that.
Realtor.com is a real
estate listing service.
And they use the Vision API's
optical character recognition
feature to extract
text from an image.
So when somebody is
looking for houses
and they use the
realtor.com app,
they can take a picture
of the for sale sign
and then be immediately
directed to the correct listing
in the app.
And realtor.com is
using the Vision API
to extract the text
from that picture
and direct them to
the relevant listing.
So these are the core
features of the Vision API.
Label detection will tell you
what is this a picture of?
Face detection will tell you are
there faces in the image, where
the face is located, and what
are the different emotions
in those faces?
Are they happy, are they
sad, angry, or surprised?
OCR was the use case I mentioned
before with realtor.com.
This can extract
text from an image.
It can tell you
where the text is
and what language
that text is in.
And then explicit
content detection,
pretty self-explanatory,
will tell you,
is this image
appropriate or not?
And this is really useful
for pretty much any site
that has a lot of user
generated content.
So you can instead
of having somebody
manually review the content,
is it appropriate or not?
You can send it to the API.
And then you only have to
review a subset of those images.
Landmark detection will
identify common landmarks
and logo detection can find
the company logos in an image.
So to show you some
of the JSON responses
you get back from
these endpoints,
I'm going to look
at face detection.
This is a selfie I took
with two of my teammates
who are actually here
at this conference.
We took this last year
in Petra in Jordan.
And face detection
returns an object
for each face it
finds the image.
The JSON response here we
see is just for my face.
So we can see that headwear
likelihood returned
very unlikely, which is true.
I'm not wearing a
hat in the picture,
although both of
my teammates are.
And then joy likelihood
returned very likely.
I was excited.
I was on vacation
taking selfies.
And it also returns data on
where different features are
in your face.
And then if we look
at landmark detection,
we can take this picture of
a pretty common landmark.
This is the Eiffel Tower, right?
It's actually not
the Eiffel Tower.
It is the Paris Hotel
and Casino in Las Vegas.
And I wanted to
see if the Vision
API could spot the difference.
And the answer
was that it could.
So it correctly identified this
as the Paris Hotel and Casino
and you'll notice that
MID and the response.
The MID is an ID that maps
to Google's Knowledge Graph.
So if you want to get more
information on this entity
you can send the ID to
the Knowledge Graph API
to get more data on the
Paris Hotel and Casino.
We get a bounding box of where
this is found in the image,
and then we also
get the latitude,
longitude coordinates
for this landmark.
We've got some additional
features in the Vision API.
One is crop hints, which
will give you suggested crop
dimensions for your photo.
Web annotations will search
the web for additional details
on your image.
And I'm going to get into
that more on the next slide.
And then document
text annotations
improves the OCR
model for the API.
So it's much easier
for it to identify text
in large blocks of text.
So if you have an image of
a menu or a business card,
it can break your text down into
paragraphs, words, and symbols.
So I want to focus a little
more on the web annotations
endpoint.
And to do that I have
this image of a car.
It's not just any car, it's
a car from the "Harry Potter"
movies.
I'm a big "Harry Potter" fan.
And it's on display in a museum.
So this is a car from
the second movie.
And I wanted to see what
entities the web annotations
endpoint was able to find.
So the first one I
found was that this
was a Ford Anglia,
which is, indeed,
the correct model of the car.
It also returned
art science museum,
which is a museum in Singapore
where this car is currently
on display.
And then finally it was
able to tell me that this
is from "Harry Potter."
So the way that
it does this is it
finds similar images
from across the web.
And based on the context
of the pages where
those other images
are found it's
able to extract these entities.
We also get, in addition
to the entities,
the web annotations endpoint
will give us additional details
on the image.
So we'll get all of
URLs where this image
has been found on the web.
So this is really
useful if you have
an app where users
are uploading images
and you want to make sure
that this image is theirs,
it's unique, it hasn't
been seen before.
You can use full matching
images to guarantee that.
Partial matching images,
exactly what it sounds.
It'll give you URLs of
visually similar images.
So this is kind of like
a reverse image search.
So we might see images of
this car in another context.
And then pages with
matching images
will just show you the URL where
all the exact image matches
were found.
You can all try this in the
browser with your own images.
If you go to
cloud.google.com/vision,
you can try it out, see if
it's right for your application
before you start writing code.
And in case you were
wondering about our sheepdog
versus mop example
from before, this
is what the API returned
for the bottom right
picture of the sheepdog.
So it's 99% sure that it's
a dog, and it's even 77%
sure that it's a komondore,
which is the exact breed of dog
that this is.
It was able to identify
this as a broom or a tool.
And I won't to show you the
response for all of them.
But the API was able
to identify three out
of four for each of
these correctly, which
is pretty good considering
that this model wasn't trained
specifically to identify
pictures of sheepdogs and mops.
And it was able to identify
almost all of them correctly.
So that was the Vision API.
Next I want to move
into the Speech
API, which exposes the
functionality of OK Google
to developers.
So it lets you implement
speech to text transcription
in your applications
in over 110 languages.
One company using
this API is Azar,
and this is a chat application.
They've connected over 15
billion matches so far.
And they're using
the Speech API.
Any time an audio
snippet is sent
between people
they'll transcribe it
with a Speech API.
And these APIs are really easy
to combine with each other.
So they're also using
the translation API.
Any time two of the matches
don't speak the same language,
they'll transcribe it
with the Speech API
and then use pipe it
through the translate API
to translate it into
the host's language.
We recently launched
a new feature
on Speech API just a couple of
weeks ago, speech time stamps.
So if you specify this
in your API request,
instead of just getting
the transcription,
you'll also get the start
and end time for each word
in your transcription, which
makes it really easy to search
for text within your audio.
So I'm going to go into a
demo shortly of the API.
Briefly I'm going to
explain how it works.
So I wrote a bash script that's
going to call the Speech API.
First it'll make
a recording using
SoX, which is just a command
line utility for audio.
Then we'll create an API
request in a JSON file.
We'll send it to the
Speech API and then
we'll receive the response back.
So let's go to the demo.
Cool.
So the way that I'm
going to call my script
is just with bash request.sh.
And it's going to ask me to
record five seconds of audio.
So I'm going to
record something.
Here I go.
I'm super excited to be in
Krakow, Poland for a Google
Developer Days Europe.
And I'm going to
send out to the API.
While I do that, this is what
my request file looks like.
It looks like it did
a pretty good job.
This is the
transcription that I got,
and it's 93% confident that
it transcribed that correctly.
| want to briefly
talk about what
the request file looks like.
So here in our
config we just need
to tell the API the encoding.
Type of our audio,
we're using FLAC here.
The sample rate in hertz.
The language code, which
if you leave this out
will default to English.
If you're transcribing
in another language
you just need to specify
the language code
that you're using.
You can optionally
pass it some phrases.
So if you've got some
proper nouns that
are specific to your
application that the API may not
recognize normally you can give
it hints of things to look for.
We can also give it a parameter
called max alternatives.
So you notice here we got three
possible transcriptions back.
So you can use max
alternatives to specify that.
And then you can pass your
content either as a base 64
encoded string or as a
URL of a audio file stored
in Google Cloud Storage.
So that is how the
Speech API works.
And I've got one
more Speech API demo
I want to show you to highlight
the time stamps feature.
So here I've got a video
of [? Orz ?] talking
about GCP's Google Cloud
Platforms pricing philosophy.
And below the video I
have the transcription
that the Speech API gave back.
Now what I can do
with time stamps
is I built a demo that we can
search through the transcript
essentially.
So if I click on this--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Google Cloud Platform del--
[END PLAYBACK]
SARA ROBINSON: We can skip to
the exact point in our audio
where this occurs.
So if I go to another--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --70%--
[END PLAYBACK]
SARA ROBINSON: --line,
you get the idea.
So the time stamps feature
I'm really excited about,
because it makes
it easy to search
a large library of video content
just using the transcription.
So the way that I did this
is I extracted the audio
from the video and then sent
that audio to the Speech API.
And I have more
than one video here.
So I've got a bunch of
videos about Cloud, Firebase.
So let's say I want to
search for all my videos
that mention Firebase.
I can do that here
and I can actually
jump to the exact moment in
the video where I see Firebase.
This video is a
screencast tutorial
about Firebase hosting.
And we can see all the points--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Firebase hosting--
[END PLAYBACK]
SARA ROBINSON: That mention
Firebase, which is pretty cool.
In this video we've only
got one mention of Firebase.
So if our job was to
look through the video
and find all the
mentions of Firebase,
chances are we might miss it.
But with the Speech
API's time stamp feature,
we're able to jump right
to that point in the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Firebase real time da--
[END PLAYBACK]
SARA ROBINSON: So that's an
example of the time stamps
feature of the Speech API.
So with the Speech API
you can transcribe audio.
Once you've got that
text transcription,
the next thing you
might want to do
is extract more data from it.
And that's where the Natural
Language API comes into play.
So the Natural
Language API, you can
extract entities, sentiment,
and syntax from your text.
One company that's
using it is Wootric,
and Wootric is a customer
feedback platform.
So what they enable
their customers to do
is if you look at that
box on the top right,
their customers place
these feedback forms
in various places throughout
their application.
And they ask them,
how is your experience
on this specific
page from zero to 10?
So they rate their
experience and then
they have this open
ended feedback.
And Wootric's job is to
help their customers make
sense of this feedback.
So it's pretty easy
for them to make
sense of the numbered feedback.
But what's much more
difficult is making
sense of that open ended text.
And they're using all three
methods of the Natural Language
API to do this.
So they're using entity
and syntax annotation
to extract the subjects
and see how people are
talking about different topics.
And then they're using
sentiment analysis just
to gauge, did the numbered
square the person line up--
line up with the open ended
feedback that they gave?
And so this enables
them to do things
like say they have a high
priority customer that's
angry about usability.
So they can route
that request really
fast to the right person.
And with the
Natural Language API
they're able to
route and respond
to customer feedback
in near real time
instead of having people
manually go through each open
ended response.
So now I want to talk about
each of the three methods
of the Natural Language API.
The first one is
extracting entities.
Obviously I have a "Harry
Potter" example again.
So I just took a
sentence about JK Rowling
from her Wikipedia
page, and I wanted
to see what entities the
API found in this example.
We got these five entities back.
And then I wanted to look
closely at the JSON response
it gave for each one.
So notice that these
are three different ways
of referring to JK Rowling.
If you're wondering,
the third one
is a pen name she used for
a different book series.
That's a topic for another talk.
But all of these map
to the same entity.
So they all point to
her Wikipedia page.
So it's able to normalize
these different mentions
of the same thing.
So in our JSON response
we get back her name,
the type of entity--
she's a person--
and then we get some
additional metadata.
We get that MID, which maps
to her Knowledge Graph entity,
and then we get the
Wikipedia URL for her.
Similarly for British, it
maps to the Wikipedia page
for the United Kingdom.
So if instead this had said
United Kingdom born novelist,
it would have mapped
to the same entity ID.
And we got a similar
one for "Harry Potter."
And if you have
entities in your text
that don't have a Wikipedia
page associated with them,
the API will also be
able to identify those.
It just won't return
anything for metadata.
So if this instead
had said my name
the metadata would be
empty because I don't have
a Wikipedia page yet, at least.
The second thing we can
do is analyze sentiment.
This might be something I might
find on a restaurant review.
The food was terrible, I
will not be going back.
If I was a manager
of this restaurant,
this is probably
something I'd want to flag
and maybe respond to.
But chances are I don't want
to go through all the reviews
to do that.
So I can use the sentiment
analysis endpoint
to get some data on the
sentiment of this text.
And it returns two values.
The first is score,
and score will tell us
on a scale of negative 1 to
1 how negative or positive
is this text?
And then magnitude
tells us regardless
of being positive or
negative, how strong
is the sentiment in this text?
And this is a range
from 0 to infinity
normalized to the
length of the text.
So since this is
pretty short we've
got a small number of 0.9.
And then the last method of
the API is analyzing syntax.
So this gives us more
linguistic details
on the contents of our text.
So here, if we the sentence,
the Natural Language API
helps us understand text,
the first thing we get
is a dependency graph.
So this is called a
dependency parse tree,
which tells us
essentially how do
the different words in the
sentence relate to each other?
This is one piece
of data we get back.
We also get the
parse label which
tells us what's the role
of each word in a sentence?
So in this example,
helps is the root verb,
API is the nominal subject.
So it tell us the
role of each word.
We also get part of speech.
So tells us is it an
adjective, a verb, a pronoun?
And then we get
[? lemma, ?] which
is the canonical
form of the verb.
So in this case,
we just have one
for helps the
canonical form is help
and this is really
useful if you're
counting how many times
a certain word appears
in the context of your app.
You probably don't
want to count helps
and help as two
separate mentions.
They're related
to the same word.
So you would use the canonical
form here to do that.
And finally, we get additional
morphology details on our text.
This is going to be a little
bit different depending on which
language you send to the API.
So this is just a
visualization of all the JSON
on you get back.
You can actually
create your own if you
go to the natural
language product page.
There is a little try
it demo in the browser.
So you can enter your own text--
I'll share a link at the end--
you can enter your own text and
generate these visualizations
as well.
So I'm going to show you a
demo specifically focused
on the syntax annotation
endpoint of how
you could actually use
that in an application.
So I've been running some
natural language processing
on tweets using the
hashtag GDDEurope.
And what I did is I wrote a
little node script that calls
the Twitter streaming API.
And I'm just looking for
tweets with that hashtag.
So the streaming API won't
give me all the tweets,
but it'll give me a subset of
tweets with GDDEurope in it.
So I'm taking those tweets,
and I take the text of them,
and I send that through to
the Natural Language API
for processing.
And then I store
that in BigQuery.
And BigQuery is Google
Cloud Platform's big data
as a service tool.
So it lets you analyze really
large data sets super fast.
So let's switch to a demo.
There we go.
OK, so this is the
BigQuery web UI.
It lets me visualize my data
stored in my BigQuery table
directly in the browser.
And here I have the schema, let
me make this a little bigger.
I've got the schema
for my table.
So I'm storing the ID of each
tweet, the text of each tweet,
when it was created, how
many followers the user has,
the hashtag as a JSON string,
which I get from the Twitter
API, the tokens, which is a
giant JSON string returned
from the Natural Language
API, and then the score
and magnitude.
So we can preview this.
Looks like we've collected
about 840 tweets so far, which
is really, really
small for BigQuery.
BigQuery's meant
for lots of data.
But this is just a demo.
So we've got the
text of the tweet,
and we've got the hashtags.
And we have this giant JSON
string of the Natural Language
API response.
And we write all our
BigQuery queries in SQL.
So you may be
wondering, how am I
going to parse this giant
JSON string with SQL?
And the answer is that
BigQuery has a feature called
user defined functions,
which lets you write
custom JavaScript functions
to parse different columns
in your table.
So here I want to find
what adjectives people are
using when they talk
about GDD Europe.
And I've written a function
just to look for each token.
And if part of speech
tag is adjective,
I'm going to do a running count.
So I'm running this query.
And let's see the results.
So it looks like pretty
positive adjectives
used about GDD
Europe, which is good.
So these are the most
commonly used right now.
And again, what's really
cool about this is this
ran this on all
840 of our tweets
and it ran really
fast, 3.1 seconds.
It ran this custom function
on all of the tweets
on our table which
is pretty cool.
I'll do one more query for you.
I'm a big fan of
emojis, so I wanted
to see which emojis are people
using most frequently when
they talk about GDD Europe.
So I'm looking at
the token again.
It looks like the laughing
crying is a popular one.
Clapping, Firebase.
Overall not too many, though.
So maybe people should use
more emojis in their tweets.
But the goal of this
demo is just to show you
what you can do with
the syntax annotation
endpoint of the
Natural Language API
to do things like
see how sentiment
is around a particular topic.
So that's the demo.
We can go back to
the slides now.
So another thing you might
want to do with text,
in addition to analyze
it or transcribe it,
is translate it
into many languages
to support all the users
in your application.
The Translation API
lets you translate text
in over 100 languages.
Before we get into it, I
want to look a little bit
at Google Translate.
So I'm a big fan of
Google Translate.
Anyone else here use it?
Looks like most people.
So I use, especially when I
travel somewhere where English
isn't the first language.
I was on a trip
to Japan last year
and I really wanted
to order octopus.
So I translated it, found
out that the word was tako.
Which I was a little confused.
But I was like, I'm
going to go with this.
So I showed it to the
waiter at the restaurant
and I did get octopus back.
So Google Translate success.
But you probably want to do
more with Google Translate
than just translate
the word for octopus.
And the translation
API essentially
exposes all the functionality of
Google Translate to developers.
One company that's using the
translation API as Airbnb.
And they actually have
60% of the bookings
are connecting people that use
the app in different languages.
And they're using the
translation API not only
to translate listings, but
also reviews and conversations.
And they found that
using the translation API
significantly improves a
guest's likelihood to book.
Here's a Python example of how
you would call the translation
API using the Google
Cloud module for Python.
And notice here
that we just pass
in the string of the text
we'd like to translate
and the target text language.
We don't need to tell
it the source language,
the API can detect that for us.
And if you also just want
to use the API to detect
the language of text, so if
you've got users inputting text
in a variety of
languages, you can just
use the detect language
endpoint to do that.
So we get our translation
result, pretty straightforward.
One improvement
we made to the API
a few months ago
was an improvement
to the model called neural
machine translation.
The way that the model worked
before with first generation
translation is that it would
take each word in your sentence
and translate it word for word.
So this is similar to what you
might do if you were traveling,
you had a dictionary
with you, and you
had a sentence you
wanted translate,
and you did a
lookup of each word.
Now, the accuracy
would be pretty good.
You'd probably get
your idea across,
but it wouldn't be perfect.
And what neural machine
translation does
is it takes the context
of each of the surrounding
words around each
word in a sentence
and it's able to produce much
higher quality translations.
There's a great New York
Times article about it
if you want to learn more.
It's available at this link,
bit.ly/nyt-ai-awakening.
And just to highlight the
differences between the two
models, I've got a "Harry
Potter" example again.
What I have here on the left--
I know there's a lot
of text on this slide,
but I'll explain it--
is the original
Spanish translation.
So "Harry Potter" was translated
into over 70 languages,
and they didn't use the
translation API to do that.
That probably wouldn't
have worked very well.
They had somebody translating
the text for each one.
So this is a paragraph from the
original Spanish translation.
And I've translated
it into English
using first generation
translation in the middle,
and then the improved
neural machine
translation on the right.
And I've just bolded
some of the differences.
So you can see these
are small improvements,
but they make a big difference
in terms of the overall quality
of the translation.
So that is the translation API.
And the last API I want
to share with all of you
is the Video Intelligence API.
This is our newest
machine learning
API on Google Cloud Platform.
And what it lets
you do is it lets
you understand your video's
entities at shot, frame,
or video level.
One company that's
using it is Cantemo.
They're a media asset
management company.
And so all of their users have
tons and tons of video content
that they're uploading
into the system
and they're using the Video
API to help their users better
be able to search large
libraries of video.
The best way to see
how the Video API works
is through a demo.
And so the demo I'm going to
show you here, what I've got
is the video of a Super Bowl
commercial for Google Home.
And I'm going to play the video.
And you'll notice that it
starts with a mountain pass,
goes through a
house, a city street.
Lots of scenes
changing in the video.
Now we see a dog.
I won't play the whole
thing, but you get the idea.
There's lots of scene
changes in the video.
And if you were to manually
transcribe what was happening,
you'd have to watch
the whole thing,
write down what was
happening in each scene,
and then maybe store those
tags in a database somewhere.
And with the Video
API, it essentially
does all that for you.
So the JSON response
tells you at a high level
what's happening in this
video, what is the video about,
and then at a granular
level, what's happening
in each scene of the video?
So if we look below this,
we can see all the labels
that the Video API returned.
So for example, it knew
there was a dog in the video,
and it knew exactly
when that dog appeared.
It knew that it ended
with birthday cake.
And if we scroll
down, we can see
it identified even the type
of dog that we had there.
And it's also able to
identify that mountain
pass from the beginning scene.
So that's pretty cool.
And this is just one video.
So chances are if you want to
analyze videos you probably
got a lot of videos sitting
around in storage buckets.
And the Video API, with the
JSON response you get back,
it makes it really
easy to search
a large library of videos.
So if you look here
I've got lots of videos.
And let's say I'm a
sports media company.
And I've got lots
of sports footage,
and I want to create a highlight
reel just of one specific type
of content.
So let's say I want
to create a highlight
reel of all my baseball
clips in my videos.
So without the
Video API, I'd have
to have somebody manually
watching all the videos to find
baseball.
With the Video Intelligence
API this is pretty easy.
So if I search
for baseball here,
we see that I get back not only
which videos have baseball,
but we can see all the scenes
that have baseball in them.
So this video is almost
entirely about baseball.
I really like this example here.
Because we've got a
long video and there's
only one tiny baseball
clip in the video.
So here we have the
year end search video
which Google publishes at the
end of every year highlighting
top searches.
And if we skip here we can
see that baseball clip.
It's actually when the Cubs
won the World Series last year.
From Chicago, so I was
pretty excited about that.
But there's only one small
baseball clip in this video.
So if somebody's job was
to scan it for that clip,
chances are they might miss it.
It's only one or two
seconds of the video.
But with the Video
API it's really easy
to make our library searchable.
So I'll do one more search.
I'm going to search
for beach, because it
might be nice to be
on a beach right now.
It's a little cold today,
it was a little rainy.
So now can't go to a
beach, but we can search
for all of our beach videos.
It's the next best thing.
So here we can find the beach
clips in all of our videos,
which is pretty cool.
So something that used
to take hours, now
with the Video
Intelligence API you
can do in seconds or minutes.
Let's go back to the slides.
So just briefly I want to
share how the demo works,
because it uses a couple of
other Google Cloud Platform
products as well.
All of the videos are stored in
a Google Cloud storage bucket.
And I've got a Cloud function
listening on that bucket.
So that Cloud
function is triggered
anytime a new video is added.
It's going to make
sure it's a video file.
And then if it is, we will send
it to the Video Intelligence
API for processing.
And the Video API
lets you pass it
in the request parameters
the URL of a different cloud
storage bucket where you'd like
it to write the annotations to.
So once it's done
annotating the video,
it's going to write all my
annotations to a separate cloud
storage bucket.
My front end is a
Node.js app that's
running on Google
App Engine, which is
our platform as a service tool.
And so the front end isn't
calling the Video API directly.
All it's doing is
getting the video
from one cloud storage
bucket and then
the associated
metadata from another.
This is what the response
looks like for label detection.
So here we have a video that
has a scene of bird's eye view.
And we get this location data.
So it's going to tell
us the start and end
time in microseconds that this
label occurs in our video.
And if it occurred
more than once,
I'd have more than one object in
my segment part of my response.
And we also got a
confidence score.
How confident is it
that it correctly
labeled the scene of our video?
So that's all I
got for the APIs.
I encourage you to try them
all out in the browser.
So as I mentioned
for the Vision API,
I showed you how you can
try that in the browser.
You can actually do that for all
of our machine learning APIs.
You can use your own
audio, text, video,
try it out, see
the API response.
And then if you want to find
the code for most of the demos
that I showed you today,
it's available in the two
repos listed there.
So I'll let you all get
a picture of that slide
real quick.
And thank you.
Thanks for having me.
[APPLAUSE]